so then I said to him James that's not
my cat that's my dad that is so funny
that reminds me of the time that might
cat get out of the house and climb that
palm tree oh you already told me that
one Oh have I ever told you about the
time that my ex-girlfriend thought a
tree was a mammal yeah you told me that
I ever tell you about the time that my
ex tree thought my girlfriend was a man
yeah you did tell me that way did I ever
tell you about the time that I almost
hung myself with my tie on purpose yes
did I ever tell by the time that I shot
a squirrel and I loved watching it bleed
yeah have I ever told you about that
yeah how ever told you about the time
yeah yeah have I ever damn have I yeah
well I guess we've run out of things to
say to each other really we haven't even
known each other that long just happens
that way sometimes I guess we'll just be
quiet now oh don't it's over
you